um who you putting on your Mount
Rushmore
of
La rap not California la
your personal Mountain Rushmore don't
got to be like who like the the you know
the
the publicly politically correct list
just your personal list
that's a hell of a question bro yeah
you know I'm saying that's a really good
question it don't matter what era we're
talking about rap music from La the LA
area the Los Angeles metropolitan area
your personal well well I'm putting Easy
E at the top of the list for any
[__] thing they've only come to
rap straight up that's me okay Eric is
number one right and then for sure this
gangster [__] for sure and so
um I'm gonna start with easy
uh
you know I gotta mention myself
of course
um
dog's been one of the greats yep
you know what I'm saying could have been
on Who band yeah yeah yeah almost yeah I
mean but like it's hard bro because like
you know 40 and short you know bro we're
talking about la oh just L.A just L.A no
California just L.A
Eric I mean easy um easy you Snoop one
more
iced tea iced tea not the ice I expected
but a good ice nonetheless because iced
tea kind of is like in my opinion iced
tea was hard at six in the morning and
all that [__] well I also feel like he's
like the Pioneer yeah of like yeah it's
like him and Eazy-E low-key like iced
tea was before easy right
in terms of just like I mean I mean
yeah
I'm not trying to age Paula but I feel
like she would know
no I see definitely I feel like was was
before like I mean iced tea was yeah and
them album covers like the power album
cover yeah well him and his lady with
the shotgun yeah ice was an innovator
bro yeah and he's 23 years straight on
SVU yeah it's crazy you know and when
you sit out and have a conversation with
him he's like one of my favorite people
to sit down and talk to yeah eyes be
popping that [__] like still still like
you gonna leave with some Jewels [__]
with ice you know you're gonna say some
players it's gentleman ain't on them man
he's gonna say some fly [__] for sure